hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play tenebrous tenebrous lake
alright don't in the dark hole of doom
ah load no matter how dark the moment
love and hope are always possible I
don't believe in love oh so little light
there is oil oh yes I'm finding all the
secrets besides the secret door which I
probably already passed oh I know now
get up here ants
antsy those cages cool ah hello well
know something you have to jump down the
waterfall I won't ever be able to get
back get up there I see a walkway ah
okay here we go okay
dammit I thought clothes not then
all right so what do I do
I can't fall off there I can't fall off
here I didn't won't let me fall off whoa
whoa what whoa what the hell what the
hell
ported me back up okay so obviously this
isn't correct guess there's something
been under the stairs I see it
oh love it mod something was under the
stairs this guy's hiding stuff all over
the place I've got like four large oil
potions now that's awesome oh I get it
more stacking but whatever at least this
is an easier stack they're stacked to
get up there there we go
so awesome I am
best at everything
another bear alright gonna go up there
do the last step on the way to glory huh
do that needs another box like this one
there huh oh oh yeah oh yeah all right
yeah yeah we are
easy-peasy okay chunk no wrong right but
oh it's already working
huh
there we go lucky day no all right on to
the next one
all yeah ah damn it okay so I'm supposed
to I guess I bring it back up now
what ah yeah wait I didn't even see it
come back up okay those aren't Katie's
other Justice shadows over the thing
being cast okay all right I got this
guys I'm an idiot but I got it you you
guys already knit watch that lamp
swinging you guys already know that it
takes me like ten times longer than the
average person to get things done
damnit I don't know oh sure yep and this
time I make it no no give me a minute
hey I'm hurt but I made it good think I
got plenty of blood on them yeah hey
success I only broke my legs right up my
rectum but that's okay a ladder who
needs a ladder I'd jump like a mouse off
giganto ledge really
you're a more large oil with so much oil
it's awesome tinderbox to out the IRS
[ __ ] operations running operations
have been moving along very well
we're completely cleared the main
chamber and have finished setting up the
lift system for moving workers we've
outfitted all of our miners in the
state-of-the-art gas masks and this
seems to have helped immensely
despite the hazardous nature of our
operation here we managed this
tremendous feed in an extremely short
amount of time and while only suffering
one cache only one this is a vast
improvement from our previous effort
note I have set up a small cache of
supplies in the crazy but I'm with the
central chamber but all usable tools are
being moved into the deepest section of
the mine or all of the digging and
drilling is currently taking place
running Foreman okay okay so basically
this guy who is that's the care once
again at the end of it though this guy
is basically a giant
ah more oil really like boom let's go so
basically the name characters I'm the
foreman but for some reason I had made
myself forget something that I did
because it was just so horrible have
encountered a monster or even a scare
okay it's going down here again why did
I need to come in here my family's dead
ha drill
see I need to skew the liquid asset you
said small cachet of supplies
and gone and the body's gone and the
body
okay okay okay okay okay
all right nothing happened
gonna happen we're all okay
we're all super happy fun times in here
what's the hell that's like floating
what gotta help show that right I was
like floating out there
nothing's on that on there hey sander
boxes gimme gimme quick quick quick
quick quick give me get on there
aha okay good good okay
so nothing's happened so far yeah yeah
yeah Sam right doing good
hey I think that's all I needed don't do
anything down there right unless I have
to go back later man this game was like
slow to build up monsters when there's
nothing left than darkness a man can do
nothing but wonder what's to become of
his soul I've never been more creeped
out by nothing
let's go get the acid for whatever
reason I oh hello
these things are hidden all over the
place it's like an easter egg huh
hello hi
markiplier here
[Music]
Hey Ya Ya here spider I probably have
already missed these there we go
turn it this drill hole right in the
center
I see okay great I got that now why why
I got that what what what what what what
where
oh no I heard something
Oh
oh ma
I'm feeling terrifying
hi I'm out of time for now let me say
drew something happened something I
don't know what but all right that's all
the time I got for this episode so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part
bye bye